I heard a guy's say the other day you
should be for things instead of against
things I like that I've been working on
it but I'm not real good at it
because there's so many things that are
wonderful to be against I mean I like
the idea of being positively I'm gonna
be proactively for something okay so I'm
gonna start this because I can't find
anything in this article I'm for there's
a whole bunch of things in here I'm
against but nothing Mpho okay I mean
like I don't nothing nothing in this Sun
for so so interesting I'll tell you what
I am for I am for you
winning with money and I'm for you
having the responsibility to make wise
choices and not be protected from
yourself so that kind of makes me like
an economic libertarian if you want to
try to put me in a pigeonhole or
something meaning I just like I like the
free market punishing people that
misbehave rather than the government
trying to fix everything every time the
government tries to fix something is
screws it up an example of that several
years ago first one of the first things
and I'm pretty sure I've got this right
it was either very early in the Obama
term or very late in the George W Bush
term but I'm pretty sure it was early in
the Obama term he formed a one of the
worst bureaus ever formed in the history
of Washington it's the worst agency ever
formed it's horrid it's called the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
the CFPB elizabeth warren formerly a
harvard law professor now senator was
the first director of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau was given
almost unlimited powers and is basically
jackbooted its
way through any part of the financial
business or industry it wanted to all in
the name of taking care of the consumer
and truthfully has screwed up a whole
lot more than it's fixed like everything
it touches it screws up its screwed up
the real estate business the mortgage
business the appraisal business it is
screwed up more than its touched and it
and a lot of stuff it tried to cause
protection for the consumers increased
cost for the consumer ridiculously
because of people in the financial world
have to run around and cover their but
in ways that are ridiculous
it assumes immediately that anyone
anywhere in the financial world is a
crook
then they just this this group is I mean
just out of control I mean their power
is ridiculous
so can you tell I have and I've never
said anything good about the CFPB on
this show so there's something I'm
against there you go see against the
CFPB okay and then you get into this
article that somebody handed me this
morning on NPR
now if NPR were to comment on something
on the Trump administration or a
Republican or conservative can you
possibly imagine that NPR didn't like it
like NPR is pretty left-leaning Trump is
pretty right when leaning like off the
scale and so you get all this political
bias in here so I don't like that I'm
against that payday lenders appear to
have a powerful friend in Washington oh
there's something else I'm against
payday lenders former Republican
representative McMullen he is the
interim head of the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau he was appointed by
President Trump amid an ongoing power
struggle for control of the bureau
there's not a power struggle for the
control of the bureau it's under the
heading of the president's guidelines
Obama held it so tightly in his hands it
was unbelievable and Trump is doing the
same thing no power struggle watchdog
groups are up in arms because under
Mulvaney the CFPB which purports to be
helping the consumer has put a hold on a
rule that would restrict payday lenders
and their high interest loans and it's
also dropped a lawsuit against online
lenders charging 900 percent interest
rates so the and turns out that this
representative is taken donations from
the payday lending industry so instead
of just shutting down this ridiculous
Bureau that Clinton are there I'm sorry
that Obama put in place Trump instead
put a guy in charge of it who at one
time apparently said it's a sick sad
joke
which that would be something I actually
would agree with and now he's in charge
of it he called it a sick sad joke and
now they made him in charge of it why
don't you just be in charge of shutting
it down and there we would be okay
instead he goes in there and starts
jumping on and stripping down and
allowing the payday lenders to run rogue
now I listen the best way to take care
of payday lenders cuz that's scum that's
a completely scummy business eight
hundred nine hundred percent interest
effectively annually and and they feed
on poor people because rich people
middle-class people don't go in those
places they're ripping off poor people I
mean it's the bottom of the barrel of
scum you know it's the scum barrel at
the bottom of the scum barrel right I
mean it's unbelievable scummy scummy
scummy business I mean really horrible
no redeeming value whatsoever our poor
people need access to borrowed money no
poor people do not need to get screwed
it makes them poorer
that's a stupid but statement just
ridiculous these loans have been found
by Congress to be so dangerous that they
have been prohibited for the military
and that was george w bush to sign that
into law that's true because they were
ripping off that we're outside all the
military bases outside the gates and
these young guys and gals are you know
nineteen years old get their first check
they go out there and they blow it and
then they get in trouble and they go
payday lending with the military
military is prohibited that now good
good let me tell you how i'd love to run
payday lenders out of business
nobody does business with them there's
your regulation that's the marketplace
regulation that's the marketplace saying
you people are scum you suck you're
ripping people off I'm not going over
there
educate poor people that are going in
those places to not go in those places
anymore because you
dying they're killing you they're
cutting your fingers and your toes off I
mean they're unbelievable I mean if we
could get everybody to understand that
you want spend some money spend some
money on educating people to not do
stupid stuff and then people that rip
people off will not be in business
anymore
it is not a benefit to poor people to
rip them off poor people need access to
borrowed capital as well that the
bullcrap that's just the stupid butt
statement just to find ripping somebody
off that's all it is so I so far I've
found nothing I'm for I'm not for NPR
bashing Trump because that's fairly
predictable I'm not for Trump appointing
some guy to the head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau who cuts
down the regulations immediately and
allows these rogue scum people to run
rogue I'm there's nothing in here to be
for there's just nothing here to be for
I'm for you staying out of payday
lenders I you know I prefer that we
don't have to have piles of regulations
to run these scum burgers out of
business
I prefer instead we educate people and
you don't do business with them because
they're scum burgers what if everybody
understood that these people are ripoffs
I never went in there then they would go
away right the marketplace would have
called them but instead they feed on the
very people who they who can least
afford it so in the interim if the
stupid Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau is actually going to exist if
you're going to run it
you oughta at least leave the
regulations in place to make it hard on
payday lenders especially online payday
lenders which is the worst of the worst
so I was a fairly negative little rant
yeah I just my god there's nothing here
to be for I can't before this
representative I can't be for Trump I
can't be for NPR I can't be for CFPB and
I sure it's crap can't be for payday
lenders so I'm just against everything
and that's the only way I know to be for
you and actually have an objective
critical thinking path in looking at
this particular issue this particular
article yeah
those NPR wrote the article so slanted
that you you have to lean your head
sideways to read it it's so slanted and
Trump is completely out of control with
a stupid process that's going on here
this guy run this thing is obviously an
idiot oh my gosh
this is nuts y'all shut the thing down
shut the thing down and you people stay
out of the payday lenders office you're
getting screwed was I unclear I hope not
this is the Dave Ramsey show